what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time and we
back
in new york city see the background
for a week and then we're going back to
miami but don't forget that block fight
is now sponsored
by lunch money hot psych is the other
way around
lunch money sponsored by block five
messed that up but you didn't even know
cause i said it was so much confidence
go to block five dot com slash pomp and
you can get an interest bearing account
you can get on the wait list for the
bitcoin rewards credit card
or you can buy and sell crypto or take
out a us dollar and get your crypto
collateral go to blockfy.com
pomp sign up today i look like new york
city like a polar bear today
okay usually like an animal come on
let's go
come on people are gonna literally click
away from the video if you don't hurry
up
are we gonna have a conversation after
this video
yeah you're gonna be talking to yourself
looking in the mirror
paypal's venmo mobile payment app will
now let users buy hold and sell bitcoin
and other digital
tokens potentially a significant step
towards moving
cryptocurrencies into the mainstream
paypal has always been a very
bitcoin forward what are they talking
about into the mainstream there's a
hundred plus million people that use
bitcoin
what are they talking about yes but
venmo has 70 million users
but how many of the users that have
venmo also have
on paper it's unclear no venmo's the
younger i've written about this
venmo's the younger audience paypal is
the older audience
and paypal bought venmo for this very
reason
what's the overlap between the users who
knows my guess
is that the users of paypal that are
using the crypto product are the same
users who have venmo
so while it is a big deal and yes this
is a positive sign a ton of overlap
paypal's more international venmo is
more u.s centric
all right moving on you knew a lot about
venmo there that was kind of weird
facebook unveils a suite of new audio
products
mark zuckerberg said facebook is
launching a suite of new tools and
designed
and featured sorry well and features
designed to help users better connect
with each other and their favorite
creators through audio
are they trying to compete with
clubhouse facebook's new short form
audio product will serve
users stream of brief clips clips of
what
zuckerberg says this product is like an
audio version of its tick-tock-like
video
product reels users can share individual
clips to their news feeds or they can
consume a string of audio clips
joined together and algorithmically
distributed in a feed
i don't see the purpose of this i think
this is very very small what is this for
this is classic facebook there is a new
trend underway
audio well new trend being the way that
people are using it drop in social audio
podcast discovery all this stuff
facebook understands one thing
the product is not the differentiator
distribution is king right there's a
saying first time entrepreneurs focus on
the product
second time entrepreneurs focus on
distribution for one second
i'm paused twitter has massive
distribution they launched
what is it twitter rooms i don't even
know what it's called cannot
over pass clubhouse
what are you talking about clubhouse
downloads are dropping out of the sky
like
like a planes that engine that went
twitter has not won that war
i'm not clear i'm not saying that
twitter won but what i'm saying is that
twitter literally snapped their fingers
they created a uh product and they got
massive distribution of millions of
people using it now
and facebook's going to do the same
exact thing distribution is king
and just because you can create a
product does not mean that it's going to
be successful but if you have
distribution
you can actually have an inferior
product and plus your distribution you
can i don't understand the sound bytes
function what i'm going to sit on
facebook and hear people's
voices back to i don't get it
yeah i actually think that that's
actually really smart it's the same
thing like
uh there's going to be a lot of bad
political takes is what it's going to be
there's going to be a lot of bad
political takes but it's also kind of
like voice notes
some people use voice notes and voice
memos aggressively
other people don't use them at all and
so it's just a user experience or user
preference my friend anna recently told
me and showed me how to use voice notes
on whatsapp
it's kind of really cool except i'm not
very good at it
okay all right that right there
ladies and gentlemen was an exact moment
where my younger immature self would
have absolutely
savaged paulina like a snake i would be
like
and i would have just got her right
there venomous strike
trust me but i did it i did not do it
i did not do it i held back but i just
want everyone to know that i held back
so she knows that i could have done it
if i wanted to
put your little hand away it's a snake
it looks like a dinosaur arm
okay you wouldn't know this
is jc would have to deal with like a
raptosaurus let's go
the second largest toilet paper
manufacturer in the us
warned that it will soon raise prices on
products from bathroom tissue to diapers
kimberly clark the company said that the
increases are necessary to help
offset significant commodity cost
inflation reflecting
higher supply costs send me this
you guys are going to know when we got
done recording because the second that
we get done recording i'm tweeting this
[ __ ]
this is exactly what we're talking about
they're saying there's no inflation
there's no inflation there's no
inflation guess what there
is inflation
prices single digit mid to high single
digits
that means five to nine percent four to
nine percent
increase but inflation is here
it is going to screw the bottom 45 of
americans do you know what the inflation
deniers will tell you
they'll say it is not clear yet whether
any of the price increases will be
passed on to shoppers and families
kimberly clark said it will increase
list prices which are the prices
paid to suppliers of a product retailers
decide what to charge
consumers at the store level this is the
dumbest thing i've ever had obviously
it's a chain
nobody's gonna be like you know what i'm
gonna lose money because i don't want to
pass it on to the retailer
oh my my goods cost more but i'm gonna
keep selling at the same price that's
not how the world works
this is insanity that people continue to
say
here's a great way to look at it if a
rich person buys toilet paper
what is the percentage of their expenses
for that toilet paper
if a person who's not rich buys toilet
paper it is a much higher percentage
they buy more goods that are affected
first and more aggressively
by inflation therefore the bottom half
of americans are about to get their
clock
cleaned because we have inflation
and when we have inflation the bottom 50
percent of americans
are much much more affected by inflation
than the top fifty percent of americans
the top fifty percent hold investable
assets
and inflationary goods are a small
percentage of their monthly expenses
the bottom fifty percent hold no
investable assets mean they don't
benefit at all
and majority or a very high percentage
of their expenses are inflationary goods
so wake up people inflation
is here when they tell you it's not
tell them to kick rocks
that's it he loves telling people to
kick rocks yeah
it's like well it's better than tell him
to go play in traffic
and that's the second thing i would say
and the third thing
from the 1960s and the third thing i
would say there was no traffic back then
and the third thing i would say is i
would look those grown men right in the
face
and i would say you're silly because
that is the most disrespectful thing you
can say to somebody
is you look a grown man right in the
eyes look at me right here we go i am
the captain now
and you just say you're silly what goes
on in your brain
okay i don't want to know actually all
right well if i'm called them silly
imagine what i'm calling you in my head
playboy playboy playboy's stock
has surged more than 80 this month due
in large part to excitement
over how it can take advantage of the
hot nft market
playboy certainly has unique offerings
no pun intended uh the ceo said look we
have an
unbelievable archive 68 years that's how
the ceo talks in my head
it is the 5 000 pieces of art we have
it's covers it's photography
it is so deep and rich in what's in
there that's what he said
so they're gonna do nfts of covers of
playboy smart
if i find out you own an nft playboy
cover
if i find out all right ready
ready um okay so the epa
approved the first release of
genetically modified mosquitoes
in the florida keys so i ain't messing
with no genetically modified nothing
so the technology will combat do you say
it dingy
dingy dang i don't know keep going just
pretending
i don't know just pretend it's a
potentially life-threatening disease
and other mosquito-borne viruses such as
zika mainly
transmitted by the 80s gypty mosquito
well there have been more than 7 300
dengue
donkey i don't know all right listen
listen listen i'm gonna take over here
let me let me help out my partner here
all right so here's the deal the
genetically modified mosquitoes and two
i'm out i'm not messing with nothing i
hate mosquitoes and i hate genetically
modified ones even worse
if i was patient and had a lot of time i
would sit with my chopsticks and when
the mosquitoes were flying around
you couldn't get okay just just let it
go everybody knows
mosquitoes fly around me and i just grab
with my hands
hashtag sorry yeah hashtag ask ellen
it's
ask lunch money time guys you didn't
have any good questions in the comments
perfect please
questions in the comments please i
i've made contact with the species
formerly known as moist
not genetically modified i am in contact
we have a call today we are going to
discuss
discussion topics and then i will report
back
so what can you give us a little bit of
a sense of what moist is like
i think i sent uh to moist
and i think i started the email off with
hello you have been a champion no i did
tell him
i didn't tell him he was a soldier
though yeah
guys you should see these emails i wish
i got emails like that well
if he was in the army and his real name
was moist he'd be known as
private moist
[Music]
all right that's it for lunch money
today she's not happy
but i don't care inflation is here
stop dealing with the genetically
modified noise
mosquitoes see ya bang bang hope you
guys enjoyed this episode of lunch money
as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends